all right cnbc which is a
financial news network on the television
uh they've got this jim cramer guy and
you know jim cramer even if you're not a
cnbc guy he's this bald guy he's always
screaming at the television and you know
ranting and he gets close to the camera
and he gets further and he's this way
and maui this guy's a real piece of work
i'm sort of indifferent to him i don't
really i don't really care about the
markets in that way it's not really my
thing but he went on a completely i mean
this is a completely
unhinged coveted rant and you tell me if
he's on drugs or drunk i mean something
ain't right here
lord knows what happened if you didn't
partake but back then anyone who refused
to get vaccinated would get ratted out
immediately because we knew that person
could hurt other people the common wheel
was
a collin will
now we're engaged in a similar struggle
with covid and eisenhower would be
aghast we have immunocompromised people
who are incubators for every variant to
come
walking around lawfully unvaccinated
that's psychotic
we have companies that have tried hard
to get people vaccinated not backing
down we have governors who want to be
president by grandstanding on a foolish
state's right issue the right to get
sick and get other people sick
so it's time to admit that we have to go
to war against covet require vaccination
universally have the military run it if
you don't want to get vaccinated you
better be ready to prove your
conscientious objector status in court
and even then you need to help in the
war effort by staying home until we
finally beat this thing
all right he's just a random lunatic
like just some ranting raving nut bag
but a couple points there
first off this idea that the
unvaccinated are hurting vaccinated
people
um well if the vaccines worked as
promised
then if you were unvaccinated you'd be
making a choice for yourself but you
wouldn't be able to infect a vaccinated
person because the vaccine by definition
would be stopping transmission of the
virus now we know that that's not true
by the way lebron james who has been
vaccinated for quite some time and he's
a big vax guy and he loves china and
he's a good us citizen because he does
whatever is politically correct uh he
has cobed now okay so obviously the
vaccines don't work as promised you all
know that which is why they're doing 87
boosters and again wrap your head in
saran wrap i should i'm not a big into
the markets guy but i should invest in
saran wrap can we let's get some saran
wrap i don't know are they publicly
traded is that a thing um
then cramer who is a money guy right
he's a markets guy a financial guy he's
upset at the companies backing down from
mandates i mean that's just absolutely
ridiculous if you want companies to be
able to make decisions for themselves i
mean just
patently absurd and by the way the
courts have said that biden's mandate
for these companies is uh
unconstitutional and they're going to
debate this in the courts but right now
companies are not being forced by the
federal government and as you know this
is a court case that's being led by the
daily wire my friend harmeet dillon
is the lead lawyer on this like this is
now up in the air as to whether
companies can do this at all then he
mocks states rights
which is basically the most important
part of our federalist system that you
can move to different states that are
more in line with your views but he's a
power hungry maniac which is what these
people are i mean they're all unmasking
themselves at all times guys if you just
give them the power if you would just
give the structure above us the power
would we all just behave better and then
we'd be safe because that really seems
like it's going to work doesn't it that
seems like it's going to work uh and
then finally he wants to get the
military involved because that always
works too right like maybe we should
just like force a bunch of people who
are you know infected to take special
showers maybe put them in camp somewhere
with that would that be good for you jim
cramer your [ __ ]